KILLED A LOT OF PEOPLE BEEN
ELECTED TO THE BALLOT GOX AS
YOU MAY KNOW.
DAN BONGINO FORMER SECRET
SERVICE AGENT NRA TV
CONTRIBUTOR AND HE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
SO A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
SAYING, DAN, AS YOU KNOW,
YOU KNOW, WHY SHOULD -- HERE
YOU HAD THIS GUY WHO WAS 19,
WAS A NUT CASE.
BOUGHT IT LEGALLY.
MAYBE WE SHOULD BAN ALL
PEOPLE HIS AGE OR UNDER 21
FROM BUYING GUNS, WHICH YOU
SAY?
>> I SAY I'M REALLY SICK OF
LIBERALS.
I MEAN LIKE REALLY SICK.
PHYSICALLY ILL LISTENING TO
THEM BECAUSE THEY CAN'T BE
SCON SIS TENT ON AN ARGUE.
I HAVE ARGUED WITH LIBERALS
ABOUT SWAWLD GUN CONTROL
WHICH YOU ACCURATELY CALLED
PEOPLE PAROLE FOR DAYS NOW.
JUST A FEW DAYS AGO A GUY
SAID TO ME YOU HAVE TO BE 21
TO BUY ALCOHOL.
I SAID YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
THE PURCHASE OF A MIND
ALTERING SUBSTANCE NOT THE
OPERATION OF A FIREARM.
YET, THIS GUY COMES AROUND
AND TALKING ABOUT VOTING, HE
MAKES THE EXACT OPPOSITE
ARGUMENT THEY ARE APPLE AND
ORANGES.
SO IS BOOZE AND GUNS.
IT DOESN'T MATTER TO
LIBERALS.
THEY WILL TELL YOU THE SAME
THING, TUCKER, ABOUT
IMMIGRATION LAWS AND
ABORTION LAWS.
THEY WILL BE LIKE, YOU KNOW
WHAT?
THOSE LAWS DON'T MATTER.
IMMIGRATION, WE DON'T REALLY
HAVE TO FOLLOW THOSE LAWS.
FING AS A MATTER OF FACT,
PEOPLE DON'T AND WE SHOULD
GIVE THEM GOVERNMENT
BENEFITS U ABORTION LAWS
DON'T PUT ANY ABORTION LAWS
ON THE BOOKS, THEY WILL ALL
BE IGNORED.
GUN LAWS, THOSE WILL REALLY
WORK.
THOSE ARE DEFINITELY STOP
HOMICIDAL MANIACS FROM
GETTING GUNS AND PREYING ON
THE REST OF US WHILE WE ARE
AWFUL UNARMED.
THIS IS SO BEYOND STUPID
THAT WE ARE ALL LOSING IQ
POINTS BY DEBATING WITH
THESE PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: I THINK THAT'S
RIGHT.
ABORTION IS THOUGHT MENTION
NEW THE CONSTITUTION BEATING
HEART OF OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS WHICH GUNS WHICH ARE
IN THE SECOND AMENDMENT IN
THE BILL OF RIGHTS THAT'S
NOT EVEN THERE I SO, I GUESS
I APPRECIATE PEOPLE WHO ARE
SINCERELY TRYING TO SOLVE
THIS PROBLEM BECAUSE ALL OF
US RECOGNIZE HOW HORRIBLE IT
IS.
BUT, ARE YOU STARTING TO
SUSPECT THAT A LOT OF THESE
SO-CALLED SOLUTIONS ARE NOT
REALLY ABOUT MAKING THE
PUBLIC SAFER BUT ABOUT
SOMETHING ELSE?
>> TUCKER, 15 YEARS IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT, AND FIVE YEARS
STUDYING THE ISSUE AND DOING
COMMENTARY ON IT THIS IS
WHAT PEOPLE HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND.
GET THIS THROUGH YOUR HEADS
AND DON'T ARE FORGET IT
THERE ARE TWO PARALLEL
TRACKS FOR GUN OWNERS, KNOCK
FOR LIBERALS, LET'S DO THIS
SLOW.
ONE, TWO.
FIRST TRACK LEGAL GUN
OWNERS, DO BACKGROUND CHECK,
FILL OUT A 4473.
YOU CAN'T BE A PROHIBIT YOU
HAD PROCESSOR, OKAY?
THAT'S HOW GOOD PEOPLE,
ONCRIMINALS GET GUNS.
THEY HAVE HAVE A TRACK
NUMBER TWO.
PEOPLE WHO STEAL THEM AND
SELL THEM ON THE BLACK
MARKET.
YOU HAVE A LAW BY THE WAY
WHICH ONLY IMPACTS GOOD LAW
ABIDING PEOPLE AND DOES
NOTHING FOR CRIMINALS.
LET ME ASK YOU THIS, TUCKER,
WHAT OTHER LAW WORKS LIKE
THAT.
BURGLARY LAW AFFECT YOU.
HAS TUCKER CARLSON EVER
THOUGHT ABOUT BURGLARIZING A
HOUSE AND THOUGHT DARN, THE
BURGLARY LAWS YOU DON'T CARE
ABOUT AT ALL U GOOD, MAXIMUM
PENALTY ARES FOR BURGLARY
LAWS.
GUN LAWS ARE THE ONLY LAW
THAT'S AFFECT THE LAW
ABIDING AND DON'T EFFECT
CRALTS ONE BIT.
THRIVING BLACK MARKET FOR
GUNS.
IT'S ABSURD.
>> Tucker: OUR IMMIGRATION
LAW US KEEP OUT MILLIONS OF
POTENTIAL SOFTWARE ENGINEERS
BUT IGNORED BY 11 MILLION
PEOPLE FROM A THIRD WORLD